when hiking in bear country make your
presence known loud and clear
any grizzly bears in the area then have
a chance to notice you and move away and
everyone stays safe because a startled
grizzly is a dangerous grizzly but if
you surprise a grizzly bear and it
attacks what should you do should you
run away play dead or fight back the
answer is B play dead running away isn't
a smart idea Grizzlies can sprint at 35
miles an hour faster than any human
fighting back against an animal that can
stand eight feet tall and reach a
thousand pounds is a serious mismatch
your best option is to play game fall
under your belly and wrap your hands
around the back of your neck bear
charging fair charge do not get stopped
get down get down
as this bear expert demonstrates ok save
guchin
your neck this position protects your
vitals the bear will lose interest after
a few swipes and move away
neck's protected face protected about as
stable as you can get you'll come out
bruised and bloody but will come out a
lot and that's how you survive a grizzly
bear attack